l'immersion commence pour les cadets de
la gendarmerie après une matinée de
cours théoriques l'heure est enfin à la
pratique les 70 jeunes vont enfiler leur
tri et calot un véritable honneur pour
eux c'est un grand honneur de pouvoir
porter un uniforme de la sécurité
surtout de l'armée là puisque c'est
l'arménie et à vraiment c'est très
émouvant ils sont partis chercher leur
équipement avec leur fameuse treillis et
leurs chaussures noires après quoi ils
se sont allés ils sont allés s'habiller
ils sont devenus pour la plupart d'entre
eux quasiment ils sont devenus enfin
militaire déjà rien que par l'aspect de
cette tenue militaire uniforme voilà on
sent quand même qu'il ya déjà quelque
chose qui se dégage un petit supplément
d'âme les cadets vont pour la première
fois à prendre un marché en ligne et en
rythme pas à pas il se crée une certaine
cohésion l'un à 3 des boîtiers pour le
amant commandant bon
le déplacement militaire ce ne se fait
qu'en groupe et au pas cadencé donc
c'est une leurs tirs aient envie de dire
que c'est une chance se fait un grand
mot mais bon faut le savoir le maîtriser
il ya clairement une cohésion dans le
dans le groupe déjà on est entre
guillemets un peu obligé parce que on
est là 24/24 ensemble mais franchement
ces semences et des bonnes personnes qui
sont là c'est pas des personnes qui sont
là pour dire pour dénigrer et c'est donc
déjà jeu de balle je pense qu'il ya sa
part bien dans le travail d'équipé
l'esprit de corps l'esprit de cohésion
et la partie fondamentale de la réussite
et du succès de nos engagements l'après
midi ces séances de tir pour ces novices
c'est une réelle prise de conscience
c'est l'une des missions premières dans
tous les cas de de protéger la
population et
et on va être amené en cas de terrorisme
et ou de malveillance on va être amené à
utiliser notre arme de service donc donc
l'entraînement l'entraînement passe par
là aussi
en fait c'est surtout pour nous rassurer
aussi pour savoir si on n'a pas peur de
larmes parce que vu qu'on sera sur le
terrain avec une armée si on a peur de
larmes celle sais pas est fait pour nous
mais c'est là la fois qu'il prenne
confiance que le gendarme il est armé h
24 sur le terrain c'est son outil de
travail entre guillemets mais il faut
qu'il part fait qu'ils aient une
maîtrise parfaite de l'armement
le soir c'est un exercice un peu
particulier qui les attendent juste
avant d'aller se coucher les jeunes sont
appelés pour une marche de 6 km en
pleine nuit on était dans nos chambres
on nous a dit de descendre que descendu
on a pris nos affaires donc sac
bouteilles d'eau et c'est tout et pour
nous a dit qu'on allait devoir enfin que
des terroristes allaient devoir nous
trouver et nous on est de voir se
déplacer en tout en toute discrétion
passer sous un tunnel ramper ou encore
se cacher un entraînement qui semble
souder ses cadets qui se sent déjà un
peu en conditions réelles rêvez-vous
sont partis c'est bon en vrai str ça
fascinant c'est juste un rythme à suivre
il faut juste écouter ce que les nos
supérieurs disent c'est pas la même
c'est en marchant rythme et quand elles
marchent avec une personne enfin quand
marche tout seul je veux dire c'est un
peu plus compliqué vous qu'il faut que
l'on surveille tout le monde
en même temps il faut qu'à chaque fois
on vérifie
si tout le monde est là il faut qu'on se
compter tout on a pu voir la cohésion au
sein du peloton donc un renforcement une
aide entre chacun et c'était un peu
compliqué dit j physique mais ça allait
on a réussi on est tous contents ravis à
mort un mois le thé
la cohésion est une valeur essentielle
c'est très simple un jour il faut partir
en intervention la cohésion fait qu'on
forme un groupe on forme un tout et en
fait chacun se connaît on connaît les
forces de chacun les faiblesses et il
faut jouer la complémentarité
garde à vous et repos le commandant
remet la traditionnelle ronde âge des
cadets de la gendarmerie de quoi
rappeler à ces jeunes pourquoi ils ont
choisi de s'engager ce stage leur donne
en fait l'avant-goût un avant goût de ce
qu'est le métier de gendarme de ce
qu'est la formation gendarmerie de
savoir que la gendarmerie ce sont des
savoirs et des savoir-faire que ce sont
des techniques d'intervention
professionnelle et lors de ses stages
ils ont une initiation en fait découvrir
qu'elles sont toutes ces techniques et
modes d'intervention des gendarmes au
quotidien de nouveaux stages se
dérouleront en février en avril les
commandes en entendent bien monter
encore en puissance en proposant des
exercices plus physique et plus tactique
une visite de la garde républicaine est
également prévue